hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to overcast Walden in the
werewolf now this is actually a game
that came out a while ago but for some
reason I overlooked it which is a shame
because it looks fantastic and
apparently a lot of you guys were
recommending it to me but it just got
buried in the emails so I'm eager to
give this a try and I shall not go there
without my loaded gun well maybe you
shouldn't put a giant red arrow right
over that place where I'm supposed to go
but I'm not really supposed to go
because I'm gonna be the 5 again anyway
how's having some trouble recording this
I wasn't able to get the initial
cutscene because for some reason it kept
crashing on me and I don't think it was
because of the game I think though
that's normal I think it was because of
the woops I think it was because of the
recording software that I was using but
either way that's all in the past I
think I got it the kinks worked out now
and I'm ready to give this a try oh hey
it's got physically interactable like
amnesia it's pretty cool ok so anyway um
I need to find a gun I'm guessing Oh
isn't it hello bullets
ammo move objects with the right mouse
button I think I figured that out
already but thank you very much ok so
where can I find a gun oh I didn't even
click on that thing in here
nope alright let's go down did I
suddenly get a lot shorter gun okay
where did those come from harder reload
ah single shot rifle eh oh by the way I
didn't mention them excuse me what's
that he'll always on fire did a bomb
just go off somewhere I didn't mention
this hunter guy um well he's a hunter I
didn't mention that already but um he
was about to be assassinated by three
dudes from some cult they were in robes
or whatnot and then he shot them after
they shot him but he shot them dead and
there was apparently a lot of blood and
things went Willy Wally wonky on
everyone well alright then I was in the
middle of the story that looks like a
creepy smile face okay okay I can't go
laughs I can't go right there's an
invisible wall and I'm going so slowly
through the water but okay no besides
that everything went to crap and he
exiled himself in his own house or
something and he needed to do that I
don't know but that's the basic of the
story in the first intro sequence
oh okay alright here we go there's oh
this is actually pretty cool this is the
level select that I didn't show you guys
before it seems to be changing because
this just used to be black here but
anyway let's go into momentum 1 Walden
didn't feel fear for years but this was
about to change
desperate screams echoed through the
mountains sounds of destruction entered
the hunters mind oh hello Raven town a
so here we go I'm assuming there's some
bad mumbo-jumbo happen to this town that
caused the destruction of the fire and
whatnot nice fire effects actually that
wasn't that bad I believe this game is
made on the Unity engine if I'm not
mistaken hello would anyone like a face
full of gun I've got plenty of bullets
to go round and my plenty I mean about
six so not that many hello
press the tab to open the mini-map all
right then oh there's a glowy goo up
there well I'm already in here Oh Oh
what is that is that a cow or a moose -
sue oh excuse me excuse me bucket get
out of my way that's a spotted one oh
boy good gravy
okay let's definitely got to excuse me
what the hell is that pardon
hello don't know where this door is
locked
maybe that's a good thing alright then
Oh more of the [ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah
no thank you I'm gonna leave it was a
glowy goo up north that looks like a
skull I'm sure that's a do that okay I'm
sure that's a good sign and nothing bad
will happen I've got a great feeling
about this one and I'm three days from
retirement what is this oh it's a head I
didn't notice it was a head
yeah I'll get it tours oh I think I'm
arms
oh yeah that's enough Oh key key look
Louie key it's all spinny ndu daddy oh
boy okay why why did you lock me in here
he's a pardon I'm coming in Oh door open
okay all right
go that's how you want to play this game
you rogue
go I'm assuming that this key goes to
this lock door in here but I'm not
entirely sure I want to open this all
right then hello Oh what is that
uh-huh it's a horsey hello horsey what
are you doing here hey lookie how about
you go to hell and die are breathing in
my left ear okay I got a key nice little
horse T oh look the spinny Chloe effect
okay something didn't just split this
horse a nap something literally took the
middle of this horse okay that's normal
yes normal did I accidentally fire a
bullet
I may have nutter yeah okay all right
I'll let Chloe goose so that leads me in
the direction that I need to go oh I'm
not sure I wanna go in that direction
in here there's nothing here squeaky why
does everything have to go oh okay some
sodas Storehouse hots can I break these
like Zelda oh those aren't pastas or
bags
it looked like BOTS
there's something over here ah okay good
I unlocked it good great good good good
I'm so happy yeah oh god another head
I'm just gonna put you over there all
right ha ha what kind of werewolf or
just tear people to pieces and not eat
them I'm not sure if I'd be happier if
they ate them but at least I wouldn't
have to look at them golly all right
anyway okay who's that I heard a squishy
hello I move okay can move these looks
like someone tried to forge themselves
up and not get to the werewolf but it
didn't work out too well
I need wet clothes to survive the flames
what does that even mean what does that
even mean
how do I get wet clothes Oh No we owe
this doors locked all right then um okay
how do I get wet clothes wait what oh oh
okay
ah please flash I guess this kind of
makes sense a little bit but not 100%
I'm not I'm not a hundred percent with
you on this one here okay ha
oh oh hi can I have that key yes I see
it can I have it
it'd be lovely if you gave it to me but
er hover are you gonna be back yeah
excuse me
bye me uh run that by me again
okay I don't think it's in my eye
door unlocked good great I'm so happy
for me ha ha ha Ellen god damn it is
that the werewolf uh hey mr. Neil is
that oh what is wha
all right then what is fear fear terror
weakness horror panic bread cowardice
what would that be living among death
but unaware of such a feeling I see it
on everybody's face however I could
never feel it in my heart
therefore I ask you gently Oh brave old
hunter put aside your courage and start
living my nightmare
teach me to start firstly I would like
you to head to the seven moon forest
located in the northeast of this village
look for some wood in light of fire wait
until it attracts the most treacherous
and venomous animal of the place and
then kill it and collect its teeth once
I read in a book that beer has only
dominated one face once I read in a book
show me I was not wrong when I decided
to spare your life my learning starts
now just as your adventure or better
your biggest nightmare attention either
writer of your story what wait a minute
does that mean you're like this is
danger in fiction and you're me and I'm
you
am i you are you me I don't know maybe
we're each other ok apparently it was
music time where am I going
ah glue glue hello are you over here
this how I get out hopefully maybe I
don't know all right
chichi squeeze hello ok so we're back at
Ojai
what is that guy doing over there
sticking his arms out like that
well then let's get to it
momento oh that's a head - down there ok
momentum to Walden was completely
tormented and
and what and what couldn't explain what
had happened in his village
who would be the mysterious who would be
the mysterious being that left him a
letter containing a challenge thousands
of questions passed through his mind but
he knew one thing
this mission is the only way to unravel
all this mystery okay I'm in the seven
moon forest now that's good I guess I'm
assuming that has something to do with
werewolves poisonous poisonous werewolf
objective make a bonfire what if I don't
want to okay
easy as that huh I just need to find
more wood hey uptime hey where's more
hello oh this is awfully convenient
almost as if it's too easy something bad
is gonna happen it's almost as if I'm
about to summon the most treacherous and
venomous creature in this area
a guy did it what now okay how many
times do I need to say no is it here yet
where is it okay okay
ah [ __ ] hell oh god damn it where are
you
reload reload the one is back yeah it's
like a panda
okay how about no Avenue I'm gonna hold
on it yeah what where can I go yet
oh you get away from me are you oh did I
get it
I did not get it I think I hit a tree
come here come here come on hey Becky
did I get ya I got ya yeah buddy yeah
buddy you're dead
Oh your snake okay you're not a very
long snake if you don't mind me
insulting you hey I got it Fang I am
poisoned what do you mean what the hell
was that
I saw something dancing in the flames
what do you mean I'm poison okay all
right I got to go up the glow igloo
what's with all the flippy floppies you
see on my mini-map how it's all flippy
flippy flippy good so weird and wonky
and wibbly-wobbly I don't know what that
all means but either way I guess oh I
guess it's music time where the hell do
I don't understand why would the guy
pull the tooth out and then just like
suck the venom out into himself or stab
himself with it does he have like some
compulsion to stab and suck everything
he sees okay that sounded wrong but yeah
you know I mean right maybe mo maybe the
uh maybe the snake like as an impulse
after it died you know I like some
snakes when his head cuts gets cut off
the body still like rise and move yeah
me every day anyone ever seen a video
about that on YouTube it's really really
really weird because um I saw this one
video where this time that blue snake
got his head chopped off and of course
the tail part was moving and everything
but the weirder thing was that the head
was still able to bite you know there's
a saying like a beheaded snake can still
bite well this one actually it's snake
rived in front of its mouth
and it bit its own tail
and that was weird myself but the
weirder part was that the tail reacted
to being bitten the tail went yeah and
then started riding and flailing about
and that's weird because the tail by
itself was able to understand that it
was being bitten or something was
attacking it and it responded without a
brain saying oh don't like biting me
it's just like and it was just a weird
bizarre thing that it snake-bitten own
tail and it was I don't know oh hello
arrow welcome back to the world of
living so good to see you again I can't
wait to move forward in this hellhole
okay oh look at that oh oh hi there what
are you doing here are you doing here
you big old snake douche okay anyway
this game is awesome I love it this is
fantastic it's just amazing
it got me quite good right a few times I
can't wait to get to the end of it but
I'm gonna break this up into it what
looks like a three-part series took me
about 1 part to get through three of
those little oh really game really
you're gonna do that on the menu screen
thank you very much so anyway I'm really
looking forward to playing more of this
I hope you guys are too thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done as always
I will see you in the next with you
or would you go
a flashback to